hi everyone
this is Grand Master Eugene Pearlstein
and together with chess calm I would
like to welcome you to today's lecture
now today I would like to cover how to
handle the closed system if you are
black now typically it's not so easy to
play against closed Sicilian if you know
that your opponent has no you know has
played this for many many games in a row
and they're quite familiar with setting
up the pieces and typically you might
actually get under very powerful attack
from white so here I would like to show
you how to take this thing out of this
opening so after E for C 593 the move
that I recommend is actually g6 this way
you avoid after 96 this pesky move there
should be five and if you're not quite
happy to play this again the Russell emo
type of positions such as efore see 5
out of 396 there should be five then g6
is highly recommended way to avoid that
and this is cork oil hyperaccelerated
dragon move order and now after g3 96
Bishop g2 Bishop g7 we have reached the
closest iliyan and really the move order
doesn't matter and G 3 D 6 and here
White has several ways to play this
opening number one white can play f4
followed by a negative 3 in castle
and I'm not going to cover too much
going into detail with this line instead
I want to mention that after f4 nine of
six nine of three I prefer to play media
Bishop g4 and for example after castles
castles h3a Bishop takes Queen takes
here why it took out the key defender
the knight on f3 now we have the outpost
for the knight on d4 and black has a
very easy plan to play Ruby 8 followed
by so the night is going to continue for
followed by the future B 5 B 4 now all
of this is covered in my repertoire book
for authors with ginger in Albert chess
openings for black explained but rather
today I want to talk about the move
Bishop to e3
we hope you enjoyed this video demo from
chess comm subscribe today to finish
this video and get unlimited access to
our full video library your membership
also includes access to chess mentor the
most advanced interactive training tool
available anywhere you'll also get full
access to the opening Explorer tactics
trainer and much much more so sign up
today and get serious about improving
your game